america right now has moved into a
period
of deep political polarization because
the left is speeding so fast to the left
i mean there's thelma and louise off the
cliff
remember 30 years ago the concept of
decriminalizing homosexuality was still
a controversial idea in the united
states
and then the united states was like well
you know what we're not gonna we're not
gonna criminalize bedroom activity which
i think is the right move
and then there's an argument about civil
unions and people like should they get
the same sort of contractual benefits as
people who are married
people two men versus a man and a woman
and people on the road like uh
sure i okay i guess and then it went to
okay gay marriage marriage that's ex
exactly the same under law and treated
with respect by everyone
and it won't hurt you and then it went
to religious institutions
have to perform gay marriages and your
child has to be indoctrinated in this
and then it went to
boys and girls since marriage now no
longer is between a boy and a girl or a
man or woman
now because of all of that we should
just recognize the truth which is that
boys and girls don't exist and so if a
boy says he's a girl and a girl says
she's a boy that means they should
compete in sports against one
like the the rush to the left on social
issues from the left
is unbelievable remember bill clinton in
the 1990s
being a pro-abortion politician still
said things like safe legal and rare
there's a baseline acknowledgement that
abortion was a bad thing
now the left speaks out about how
wonderful abortion is abortion is an
asset
don't tell me that the right has gotten
more right-wing it's just a lie
all that happened is that the right
stopped surrendering on every single
issue
because they finally reached some core
issues they couldn't surrender on
it's the left that has pushed these
culture wars it is the left that has
decided to polarize americans
around issues that would have been
considered absolutely
uncontroversial even 10 years ago 10
years ago it would have been considered
an uncontroversial idea that a boy is a
boy and a girl is a girl that would have
been considered
absolutely conventional in 2010 2011.
now you say that sort of stuff and
you're afraid that your business is
going to fire you
the left's culture wars have driven this
and then the left says well if we can't
get done what we want to get done it's
the checks and balances that have to go
the woke cultural left has moved into
the governmental left okay and that
merger is creating
tremendous rifts in american public life
who started that the left did the left
has been rushing
so fast to the left it's a remember
bernie sanders was a fringe figure
10 years ago now bernie sanders is
considered a thought leader of the
democratic party you think the squad
would have any power in the democratic
congress 15 20 years ago
absolutely not they'd be seen in exactly
the same way as cynthia mckinney was
seen
inside the democratic party who was the
last democrat who apparently democrats
were able to condemn
for overt anti-semitism now you have
ilhan omar and rashida talib and
alexander ocasio-cortez leading the
squad as an ideological threat inside
the halls of congress
don't tell me the right started this
fire that's a lie it's not true
donald trump didn't start this fire he
was a symptom not a cause
as i've said many times donald trump
himself i know the left wants to treat
it as though the universe began spinning
when donald trump became president but
that's not true
he performed exactly in line with other
republican candidates
he went about the same percentage of the
popular vote as mitt romney did the
reason for that is because the left
has created a a hard core on the right
of people who are going to resist them
and the more they push the more
resistance there will be and then of
course they'll blame you
and they'll blame democracy the battle
for the culture is heating up
we here at the daily wire are making
some big moves so be sure to like
subscribe ring that bell because you're
not going to want to miss a single
moment